l'humoriste François Guédon sera à la
Royal Factory de Versailles ce soir
ainsi que le vendredi 14 avril et le
samedi 15 avril il présentera son
spectacle le procès Guédon et il est
avec nous à distance pour en parler
François Guédon bonsoir
bonsoir à tous bonsoir à toutes alors le
procès Guédon en quelques mots c'est
votre propre procès à vous vous êtes
accusé par le public de ne plus rien
respecter la religion les philosophes et
vous vous défendez vous-même
exactement c'est l'idée c'est de on est
dans une société où tout devient un
petit peu le procès ou les réseaux
sociaux sont aussi dans une mesure un
grand un grand procès donc je m'étais
dit que cette formule et cette forme en
termes de mise en scène était
intéressante
il y a l'autodérision il y a le comique
de situation de gestes vous votre point
fort c'est plutôt les mots que vous
utilisez les mots pour faire rire les
gens
oui oui enfin je pense qu'on utilise
tous les mots après moi c'est vrai que
j'ai de par ma formation j'ai fait une
prépa lettre j'aime beaucoup les mots et
puis j'aime bien tourner en dérision
aussi le côté gardien du temple de la
Littérature de ces gens qui me disent on
ne peut pas toucher à racine on ne peut
pas toucher à Molière et ben si tout
change
oui d'ailleurs durant ce procès vous
vous défendez en disant que vous êtes le
seul qui puisse réconcilier Nabilla avec
racine
oui oui après je pense que je suis le
seul aussi à vouloir peut-être cette
réconciliation mais c'est l'occasion
d'un sketch ou j'imagine et si racine
avait écrit Les Anges de la télé-réalité
qu'est-ce que ça aurait pu donner et
c'est un sketch où il y a Jean Karine
timberley et Kevin qui parle en
alexandrin mais avec des mots
d'aujourd'hui
c'est pas parce qu'il y a des nouveaux
mots dans la langue française que c'est
que c'est un problème moi je suis en
défenseur d'Aya Nakamura dans le texte
et sur la piste de danse
quel message vous souhaitez faire passer
durant votre spectacle
bah je pense disons que c'est mon avis
je prétends pas avoir raison je pense
qu'on peut rire de tout je pense qu'on
doit rire de tout et que il faut savoir
voilà ne rien s'interdire dans le choix
des sujets ou dans la manière de les
utiliser et c'est pour ça que je mets
notamment la littérature et la
télé-réalité c'est dire on a des
nouvelles formes de culture il faut s'en
emparer et il faut il faut les parodies
il faut faire des pastilles il faut il
faut s'amuser avec tout ça vous avez
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas
rire de tout mais en tout cas qu'il faut
faire extrêmement attention à tout ce
qu'on dit pour pas attirer de
commentaires négatifs du public
je pense que c'est une très bonne chose
qu'on qu'on ne puisse plus faire les
sketchs de Michel Leeb où il dit que les
noirs ont des grosses narines ça je
pense que c'est vraiment c'est mais oui
c'est c'est important de se poser des
questions sur le fait de pas offenser
les gens mais il faut pas que cette
volonté de ne pas offenser
Vienne nuire à la capacité de l'humour
justement à déranger parce que l'humour
ça doit toujours rester quelque chose de
grand son
alors Gabriel une journaliste un plateau
aussi une question pour vous oui bonsoir
est-ce que vous vous êtes servis
justement de critique que vous avez
vous-même reçu pour pour ce spectacle
je me suis pas vraiment servi de
critique mais
quand j'ai et je ne citerai pas son nom
mais une responsable de médiathèque qui
me dit qu'on a pas le droit de toucher à
racine je me dis que j'ai exactement
raison de toucher à raser parce que
c'est ces personnes là aussi que j'ai un
petit peu envie de déranger et c'est et
c'est ce type de littérature que j'ai
envie de dépoussiérer mais pour le pour
le bien commun
alors est-ce que durant votre spectacle
vous interagissez beaucoup avec le
public
alors moi je suis plutôt de l'école du
Théâtre et de l'école du sketch mais il
y a notamment un cours de philosophie
sur les rappeurs ou le public sont mes
élèves donc où j'interagis avec eux sur
des notions comme
l'existentialisme ou le bouddhisme
et donc ce soir on a aussi avec
ah oui on a pas entendu la fin ce soir
on est aussi avec le gérant d'une
librairie et donc je crois qu'il a aussi
une question pour vous justement sur le
printemps des potes il y a Booba qui a
fait un recueil de poésie savoir si ça
avait été un support aussi pour vous
parce que c'est vraiment du Booba dans
le texte et voilà c'est ça c'est un bon
un bon carton en librairie indépendante
en tout cas ça fonctionne bien
c'est moi je pense c'est en plus c'est
une des phrases du sketch que le rap est
une nouvelle forme de poésie non je
plaise je ne sais pas moi Finkielkraut
par exemple et je vais un petit peu plus
loin dans ce cash en disant que il y a
une forme de il y a une forme de
philosophie dans le rapport je fais un
rapprochement par exemple entre le
stoïcisme et Jul que je trouve que je
trouve pertinente mais c'est très bien
de toute façon que les gens lisent que
les gens écoutent et si ça doit passer
par le rap et bien passons par là
il y a des grosses passerelles
effectivement entre la poésie et la
culture et le rap donc et je pense que
le rap aussi c'est pour faire attirer
des un public plus jeune
ou pas forcément oui disons que dans ce
type de sketch là j'apprends ce qui est
l'existentialisme au moins de 25 et je
fais découvrir Booba au prix de 25
alors là on voit vous êtes dans une
salle sombre vous être à la Royal
Factory de Versailles vous êtes en train
de répéter
vous êtes actuellement en direct des
loges de la Royal Factory à Versailles
ou François gallon se produira ce soir
demain et après demain soir ou après
l'assurance on vient de finir les
réglages et le spectacle commence d'ici
2 heures 30 il reste des places encore
ou pas il reste encore pour ce soir un
petit peu moins pour vendredi et samedi
mais n'hésitez pas
et bien merci François Guédon d'avoir
répondu à nos questions si vous êtes
intéressé le spectacle le procès guidon
se tiendra le 14 et le 15 avril ou dès
ce soir à la Royal Factory de Versailles
début du show à 20h30